- I feel free when I fly the balloon.
The feelings.
The goosebumps that you get.
It's amazing.
(soft upbeat music)
Living in Dubai gave me the opportunity
to do something that I love.
You don't realize the
real beauty of the desert
until you see it from above.
- My name is Mark Beaumont,
and I'm an endurance athlete.
With the current world record
for cycling around the planet,
seeking adventures and finding stories
is what I'm most passionate about.
Ever since I can remember,
I've had that sense of
curiosity about the world.
(water bubbling)
This time, I've come to Dubai.
(uplifting music)
When I travel to anywhere new,
it doesn't matter where
I am on planet Earth,
I try and get to the high point.
Whether it's the highest
building or the mountain,
to get a perspective on
where I am; I love that.
I met with Edgora, a mum
of two and in training
to become UAE's first
female hot air balloon pilot
to explore many of the heights of Dubai.
- My name Edgora. I'm from Uzbekistan,
and for the last 16 years
I live here in Dubai.
I'm a hot air balloon
pilot in training, a wife,
but most importantly, I'm a mother.
My daughter, she's five
now; my son, he's three;
and Dubai is one of the best
cities to have children.
There is so much to do;
you can entertain them
everyday, different stuff.
After trying my first flight
with Balloon Adventures,
being in the basket, the
balloon floating through the air
and absorbing the whole
beauty of the flight
made me think, OK, this
is what I want to do,
and my interests quickly
became my passion.
To be first female hot air
balloon pilot in the UAE
makes me feel very grateful,
and I hope I can encourage
other women to follow their dreams,
because that would make feel very honored.
The feeling never changes each
and every time you take off;
you always feel like, "Wow."
I always feel the
goosebumps; it's always nice.
You'd never get used to that;
it's just magical, each and every time.
- When you're driving through the desert
it kind of looks quite samey,
but when you fly above it, it's incredible
how much change there is,
especially at that first light.
When they turn the engines
off, you hear nothing.
That's beautiful, and
you've just got the view
and that space and that
incredible horizon.
I've got to see so much
of Dubai during this trip,
but that's a different perspective.
To fly over the desert is a
pretty extraordinary view.
It's unlike anything
I've done; it's unique.
- [Man] One, two, three--
- [Group] Good morning!
- Being adventurous, it is about the want
to not just observe the world
but the want to experience it.
To make your own mind up,
to think for yourself.
It's intrigue; it's interest.
It's wanting to do things and explore
and to ask the questions.
- To be a hot air balloon pilot
makes me feel very proud, very grateful.
From the first time that I
was in a balloon and now,
I feel that I have accomplished a lot,
and I'm looking forward to
getting more and more experience
and to share my passion with others.
(motivational music)